wearable body tech Fitbit FuelBand gear
glass Google glass and other ways to
complete your glass whole look and now
it's time to throw away every Apple
product into the electronic waste land
of planned obsolescence because the
Apple watch has landed and you want it
just cuz yes CEO Tim Cook recently
unveiled the latest way to become a
cyborg a mini computer for your wrist
Siri couldn't get any closer unless you
were an intake correctional officer you
can get emails texts calendars maps and
music all on your Apple watch made of
solid gold you can also use it as a
credit card track calories and monitor
your heartbeat which you can share with
others just so they know you might be an
insufferable techie but you're still
alive it's got tactic technology that
taps you when say you need to turn left
simply put you'll never have to think
again does it tell time sure but who
cares Forbes gushed that the watch could
utter lee disrupt the modern business
world in layman's terms your boss can
digitally harass you 24-7 this little
bugger will know more about you than you
do but what if all that health and
financial data falls into the wrong
hands considering the NSA has
unadulterated access to all iphones
thanks to the software dropout jeep you
can bet your heart rate will clue Big
Brother in as to how you really feel
about Jane and a cat
still want it hurry up because the
kool-aid in cupertino is going fast
subscribe on youtube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook